functional training and beyond is a book
for everyone that aims to explain and
demystify the topic of functional
training
to start a discussion on what it means
to be truly fit and to provide a road
map to a more fully functional mind and
body it's time to find out
just what you're capable of hey there
guys it's finally here
my own personal copies of functional
training
and beyond which i'm going to be opening
now for you
live on camera doing an unboxing which
is not the kind of thing i normally do
on this channel
you could tell it was going to be a
different video because i have my top on
for a nice change
i think i've got about 15 copies here
which is the minimum i recommend
anybody order i presume that's what
you'll be doing
let's get into this thing it's got an
awful lot of sellotape on it
so this could take a while
this is the point of which i'll probably
speed up the footage
don't want to cut the book very excited
about this
obviously i've been working on this for
months i think coming up for a year
and i'm finally going to get to see i've
seen pdfs
and they look good for those
who have been asking the book will be
available
on kindle
and it's also going to be available at
some point
on audible i believe but i don't know
the exact date but i have
personally recorded the audio so it
should be
goodness me
let's see a glimpse let's have a look
and there it is
looks good got a nice matte cover which
is something that i
personally requested
[Music]
yeah they've done a fantastic job with
it the publishers are mango
and they've been fantastic every step of
the way really nice bunch of people
and yeah you can tell that they you know
really care about the products they put
out it's got hand-drawn illustrations
by yours truly because for some reason i
decided
that was what this book needed giving
myself a whole lot more extra work to do
write the theme too and sing the theme
tune so yeah a lot of people have been
asking
what this book is how it's different
from super functional training which is
my ebook and training program that i've
been selling for a while
and the short answer is that basically
this one as the title
functional training and beyond suggests
is a book all about functional training
in particular super functional training
is a full program with a diet plan etc
etc
and it has lots of extra materials and
videos this is a a book a much more
in-depth exploration of functional
training and
explores why we need functional training
why i think there's something that more
people should be doing and it's the
future of fitness and it talks about
lots of different examples and styles of
training and how they each contribute to
a more
functional lifestyle things like
movement training like
sandbags kettlebells like old-time
strongmen training it also talks about
things like bodybuilding and
powerlifting what they contribute
and why you also need things like cardio
and mobility as well it's got tons of
exercise recommendations the history of
functional training
other underground forms of training that
you possibly haven't heard of
just hopefully loads of ideas and new
things to consider
for your own workouts and general
fitness and it's not just for athletes
and people who want to take their
performance to the next level
although obviously there's a lot in
there for people who are interested in
improving themselves when it comes to
their sports and things but it's also
for anyone who just wants to
move a bit better to feel more energetic
it's also got a lot about brain training
and why it's impossible to separate
functional movement from cognitive
performance it talks about how we should
be training our brains as well as our
bodies
and every aspect of our performance in
general in short it's the
philosophy of the bioneer that i talk
about all the time on this channel
but in book form with tons of practical
takeaways
and hopefully things to think about and
yeah available
from amazon 19th of this month if you're
in the us
and you can get it everywhere else as
well barnes and noble water stones here
in the uk
all kinds of other places i'll put the
links in the description down below
and yeah i'm also going to be doing a
giveaway three signed copies all you
have to do is head over to the
facebook page of the bioneer again link
in the description down below
there'll be a post there and all you
have to do is like the page and then
like or comment or both
the post that's right there you'll see
the one head over there and i'll pick
three people at random to receive a
signed copy
thanks so much for your support guys and
i'll leave you with a
short little trailer that i made for
this book and
yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna be reading this
now super excited to
see my work finally in print thanks time
for watching guys
i'll be back to our usual programming
next time i'm going to be discussing a
functional training program for
beginners if that sounds good then i'll
see you then
thanks a ton and bye for now functional
training and beyond is a book for
everyone that aims to explain and
demystify the topic of functional
training
to start a discussion on what it means
to be truly fit and to provide a road
map to a more fully functional mind and
body
unlike training programs that are only
concerned with burning fat or squatting
heavy weights
functional training is training for
function it's about being able to move
with power
grace and confidence in a real world
setting
functional training has long been used
by sports coaches to help athletes rise
to the top of their game
but it also has great value for the rest
of us because everyone could benefit
from being a little more athletic
whether you're a stay-at-home mom or dad
who constantly puts their back out
lifting the little one
or you're a busy office worker who'd
like to have some energy left at the end
of a long day
that's where sandbags kettlebells bands
battle ropes and medicine balls come in
or calisthenics and more compound lifts
you don't need any specialist equipment
to get started with functional training
the key is to move in multiple planes of
motion and to use the whole body as one
powerful system
to train the different energy systems to
me fitness relates to all aspects of
human function
a truly functional program should pay
equal attention to strength
endurance mobility balance even
cognitive performance
why not train the brain like you train
the body because imagine what it would
be like to be a little bit stronger
a little bit faster a little more
energetic and a little bit sharper
all at once it's time to find out just
what you're capable of